อาร์สยามพี่เอ๋สวัสดีค่ะน้องอาร์ตี้
สวัสดีคณะนักเรียนเย้กลับมาเจอกับครัวตี้
ครูพี่เอ๋ในช่องคอม frenzel ไทยโอเคครับ
แล้วก็คลิปนี้เป็นคลิป
คลิปคลิปที่สุดท้ายเป็นเดี๋ยวนะเป็นคลิป
ปิดท้ายของซีรีส์ต้องเที่ยว
a  r กลับก่อนที่จะคุยกันวันนี้วันอะไร
ค่ะวันนี้ใช่ไหมครับปากกาแค่วันนี้วันวัน
นี้วันอะไรดีครับวันนี้ขึ้นคฤหัสถ์มัน
พฤหัสก็ได้ค่ะสีแดงๆส้มๆดีค่ะเธอก็ผมวัน
ที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 14 ครับวันนี้เดือน
อะไรคะเงินนี้เดือน
กรกฎาคมรักขณาคมวันที่ต้องคิดตลอดเวลา
เพราะว่ามันเกินอะไรเพราะว่ามัน ju ก็จะ
เป็นจูนกับ July  God อาญาอย่างนี้ต้อง
กรกฎาคมกระดาษนะ
คือพูดได้สองอย่างนะคะจะรักอดากรรม
กรกฎาคมใช้กับกรกฎาคมกรกฎาคมนะคะเออปีพตต
ปีพ.ศ
2565 ครับค่ะปีคศอะไรคะปีคศ 2000  22
ครับค่ะตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะตอนนี้เวลากี่
โมงครับวันนี้เรามาเจอกันเร็วหน่อยครับ
วันนี้เจอกันตอนบ่ายครับเย้
กำลังร้อนในขนาดกำลังเรื่องข้าวมา any
เนื้อตกนะ
บ่ายโมงกี่นาทีครับ
13:20 น
13:20 นโอเคๆทั่วประเทศไทยค่ะโอเคค่ะ
คลิปนี้เป็นคลิปสุดท้ายท้ายสุดของซีรี่ส์
นี้ใช่ครับมันก็ไปเที่ยวที่ไหนกันมาบ้าง
ครับกูเราไปเที่ยวทั้งภาคเหนือให้กำไร
จังหวัดเลยใช่ไหมคะอีสานอ้างอะไรให้มันตก
ต้นตกให้อ่านใต้ใช่ครับน่ะแต่ก็มีมีบาง
จังหวัดที่ครัวตี้ก็คิดว่าบางจังหวัดก็มี
ที่เที่ยวที่น่าสนใจอีกแต่เราก็พูดไม่หมด
เพราะเวลาเราไม่พอไงได้ที่คือเวลาเวลา
ครึ่งชั่วโมงเนาะเราก็เอาทุกที่มาปกตินะ 1
ชั่วโมงแล้วก็จะพูดที่เดียวเฮ้ยประเทศไทย
77 จังหวัดหน่อยค่ะบ่ก็เที่ยวไม่หมดนี้
ครู Arty ก็เลยอ่ะรวมสลัดนะคะใช่กับรวม
หลายๆจังไม่มีที่ที่โคตี้คิดว่านักเรียน
น่าจะชอบนักเรียนน่าจะอยากไปก็เลยออกมา
รวมๆกันเอามารวมกันยังไงเหมือนคำสนัดเลย
ใช่ไหมครับ
งั้นเนี่ยคลิปนี้กว่าตีจะพาไปหลายๆป่าวไป
ไหนจังหวัดเลยนะครับที่แรกที่ลากเดี๋ยวพา
ไปเอ่อภาคเหนือก่อนผ้าไปดูธรรมชาติสวยๆนะ
ครับ
ที่ไหนคะ 5 พาไปที่นี่ครับ
มีอันเนี่ยไทยหรือนี้แล้วคิดถึงที่ไหนคิด
ถึงญี่ปุ่นเลยหรอคิดถึงๆๆก็
เพลง Sakura
ไม่ได้เห็นซากุระ 3 ปี 4  4  5 ปีแล้วสิ
ตาลและ service นะสามปีแต่กูเองไม่ได้ไป
ญี่ปุ่นน่ะ 5 ปีแล้วอ๋ออ๋อคิดถึงจังนะไป
ที่นี่ก่อนครับที่นี่เขาก็ถือว่าเป็นอ่ะ R
ที่ที่มีสะกุระเมืองไทยขอเป็นซากุระจริงๆ
หรอคะอ่าไม่ใช่ครับ
เป็นก็ยังเหมือนเปลี่ยนหน้าครับอ้าว
เปรียบเทียบหอมเหมือนกับซากุระที่ญี่ปุ่น
แต่อยู่ที่ประเทศไทยค่ะคือจริงๆดอกเขาก็
เหมือนกันนะคล้ายๆเลยนะใช่ไหมเรา
ที่ไหนคะครู Arty ที่อยู่ที่จังหวัด
เชียงใหม่ครับนักๆเชียงใหม่หลายๆคนน่าจะ
รู้จักที่นี่ด้วยนะที่ดอย
เชียงใหม่เนี่ยภูเขาเนี่ยเขาเรียกว่าดอย
ใช่มั้ยอ่าๆไปครับอีสานให้เขาเรียกว่ากู
อ่ะเป็นภูอ่านเชียงใหม่ทางเหนือเชียงใหม่
ขึ้นเหนือขึ้นดอยดอยอะไรคะค่ะดอยชื่อดอย
อ่างขางครับดอยอ่างขางดอยอ่างขางจังหวัด
เชียงใหม่ครับสวยจังเลยพี่อาทิจอีหน้า
เป็นที่พักเป็นรีสอร์ทหรือเป็นบ้านคนอ่ะ
ตรงนี้เป็นที่พักครับเป็นรีสอร์ทแต่ก็มี
บางที่บางที่อยู่อีก Ru อีกบริเวณใกล้ๆ
กันก็จะเป็นที่พักของชาวเขาก็มี
5 ไซร์ครับแล้วก็มีรีสอร์ทน่าจะบอกว่ากู
เองไม่เคยไปดอยอ่างขางเลยเราไม่เคยไปเหรอ
ครับคือไปไปดอยอินทนนท์อ๋ออยู่คนละด้าน
กันไปคนละด้านกันใช่ครับไปเชียงใหม่หลายๆ
ครั้งแต่ไม่เคยไปดอยอ่างขาง
โอเคโอเคกวนติ๊กเคยไปประมาณน่าจะ 3 ครั้ง
3 ครั้งเกินไปแต่ดอยดอยตุงไม่ได้ตรง
จังหวัดในตู้อยู่เชียงราย
จงเคยไปน้อยอินทนนท์เคยไปหาเอาไปดอย
อินทนนท์ก็ต้องไปดอยปุยดอยสุเทพอยู่ใต้
ดอยสุเทพเคยไปก็ได้ครับหือชอบสีชมพูอ่าก็
จะมีต้นไม้เนี่ยที่มีดอกสีชมพู
ตามถนนยาวไปถ่ายรูปมีแต่หลายคนชอบไปถ่าย
รูปกันที่นี่ประมาณเดือนอะไรคะที่น้ำต้น
ไม้ไปหาถ้าต้นไม้สีชมพูก็เป็นช่วงหน้า
หนาวกับช่วงปลายปีปลายปีถึงต้นปีมันน่าจะ
ประมาณเสือจิการกุมภาพันธ์ก็ยังมีอยู่จ้า
อ่า
แต่อาดอกไม้สีชมพูอันเนี่ยจะบานประมาณ 7
วันหรือ 10 วันใช่ครับใช่ครับจะบานไม่นาน
ประมาณอาทิตย์นึงอาทิตย์ไม่อาทิตย์ถึงสอง
อาทิตย์ค่ะประมาณก็จะรวงนะครับร่วงหล่นบน
ถนนบนพื้นถนนก็จะมีดอกไม้สีชมพูเต็มไปหมด
เลยใช่ครับครู Arty
ไม้สีชมพูอันเนี้ยอ่ะทีเร็กซ์ซากุระเมือง
ไทย
อ่าจริงๆแล้วเขาชื่ออะไรคะอ่ะเขาชื่อดอก
พญาเสือโคร่งใช่ไหมหา
พญาเสือโคร่ง
น้ำเหมือนแต่เขาเหมือนซากุระป่าหรือ
ซากุระภูเขาที่ญี่ปุ่นเลยนะอ๋ออ๋อเหรอ
ครับแต่จะกูรับปากว่าจะสีอ่อนกว่านี้นิด
นึงกูเอกเคยเห็นสกุล up ป่าที่ที่ภูเขา
เพื่อนบอกนะเก๋นะพญาเสือโคร่งซากุระป่า
เหมือนกันไหมคุย
ไม่รู้อะไรที่ไม่เหมือนกันมีความใกล้
เคียงกันนะคะไปขายกันสะนาเอ
สวยจังเลยนะคะต้องไปกับช่วงหน้าหนาวอ่ะไป
นอนพักได้มีบ้านพักน่าจะเต็มนะคะ
ต้องจองล่วงหน้าครับเพิ่งจองหน้ากูเอก
เป็นคนไม่ค่อยมีแพลนนานๆนักเรียนคือถ้า
ถ้าจะไปไปที่แบบเนี้ยอ้ะที่มีเวลา 7 วัน
น่ะฉันต้องจองล่วงหน้าประมาณ 2 เดือน 3
เดือนไหมหาอาได้ครับต้องจองล่วงหน้าแต่
บางครั้งถ้าจองล่วงหน้านานๆเราก็จะเท่ห์
ดอกพญาเสือโคร่งจะบานเมื่อไหร่ไม่รู้อีก
จองแล้วโอเคคือถ้าคิดจะนอนใกล้ๆที่มีดอก
พญาเสือโคร่งอ่ะค่ะก็ต้องจองล่วงหน้าแต่
ถ้านอนไกลๆแล้วก็ขับรถไปดูอันนี้โอเคๆๆ
ครับอยู่ถ้าจะไปนอนแถวๆนั้นแต่ที่นอนไม่
มีมีที่ให้กางเต็นท์ด้วยครับยังเต้นได้
กลางเต็มครั้งนึงคืนที่กลางเป็นครั้ง
หนึ่งไงอ้ะก็สนุกดีครับแล้วก็ตอนเช้าก็
ขับรถมาดูแลได้ไปๆจัดการเต้นหนาวมากใน
กว่าตีหน้ากลางเป็นก็หนาวนิดหน่อยครับนิด
หน่อยตอนนั้นไปมีการอ่าน 15  16 องศา
อ้าๆเอาไปนอนข้างล่างแล้วกัน
นอนข้างล่างคือตอนนี้อยู่บนภูเขาใช่ไหม 15
16 ปีเข้านอนข้างล่างแล้วก็นั่งรถขึ้นมา
ดูนอนข้างล่างมีมีมีบ้านต้องทำน้ำอุ่นและ
ไม่ชอบหนาวหนาวไปนอนเต็นท์ก็สนุกดีครับ
สนุกแล้วอะไรก็ไม่ได้เสียงเด็ก
ไม่มีอะไรนะประเทศถุงนอนครับนอนในถุงนอน
อุ่นอุ่นๆๆถ้ามีถุงนอนก็ไม่หนาวเนาะโอเค
ค่ะอ้าโอเคดอยอ่างขางนะครับเดี๋ยวเราไป
กันต่อไปที่อื่นแล้วไม่มายรอยอะไรนะครับ
บ๊ายบายดอยอ่างขางขายรูปเสร็จแล้วเดี๋ยว
เราไปออเดี๋ยวพาไปที่นี่ครับเดี๋ยวให้
Grey ดูรูปก่อนนะอ่า
โอ้นี่หำเอออันนี้ไม่รู้จักจริงๆรู้จัก
ว่ะอันนี้อยู่เอ่อลงจากเชียงใหม่ลงมา
หน่อยนึงนะครับอ่ะที่จังหวัดอะไรคะ
จังหวัดเพชรบูรณ์ครับเพชรบูรณ์อยู่ตรงนี้
นี่โอเคไปเช่นเชียงใหม่อยู่นี่เพชรบูรณ์
อยู่นี่นี่ครับเฮ้ยเคยไปเพชรบูรณ์อะไร
ครั้งไปไปที่ภูเขา
ไม่เคยไปที่นี่ไม่เคยไปที่นี่ใช่ไหมครับ
เดี๋ยวนะคะตีทำรูปหายไปแล้วก็แค่อยู่ที่
นี่เปล่า
อาเล่นชื่อวัดพระธาตุผาซ่อนแก้วครับเคย
ได้ยินชื่อนะคะ
กับรูปปั้นของพระพุทธเจ้าหรือเปล่าคะเป็น
รูปปั้นของพระพุทธเจ้า 5 พระองค์คุณเจ้า
ห้าองค์นั่งเรียนกันอยู่เป็นแถวองหน้า
องค์เล็กที่สุดแล้วก็ค่อยๆใหญ่ขึ้นมาใหญ่
ที่มาอย่างน่ามีหัวหน้าพระองค์ขอในกับนี้
นะมี 5 เท่าไหร่ครับอ่าหนาวเพราะผมรอบรอบ
ก็จะเป็นดอกบัวสีขาวใช่ค่ะเป็นดอกบัวสี
ขาวสวยจังเลยสวยครับอยู่บนภูเขาเหมือนกัน
บนภูเขารถขึ้นไปได้ขับรถขึ้นไปได้ครับมิน
ลานจอดรถอยู่ใกล้ๆด้านหลังนี้แล้วก็เดิน
มาเดินขึ้นเขามานิดนึงประมาณ 20 เมตรไม่
ไกลไม่ไกลอ่าใช่ครับขับรถไปได้ขับรถไปได้
ได้ค่ะจะได้ถ้าขับรถไปได้คุยอีกไปได้เรา
ก็ไปเดินชมวิวรอบๆนี้ครับตอบก็เป็นเป็น
หน้าผาค่ะดูภูเขานะคะๆครับลูกภูเขาตอน
เช้าๆเมื่อเช้าก็จะมีหมอกบริเวณใกล้ๆก็จะ
มีที่พักนามิรีสอร์ทให้รีบผลักได้นะครับ
เพชรบูรณ์อากาศดีนะคะค่ะใส่กับเพชรบูรณ์
เป็นเมืองที่อากาศดีมีต้นไม้ถ้าไม่มีป่า
เยอะชายเขาบอกว่าเพชรบูรณ์เนี่ยถ้าจะไปดู
แล้วสวยต้องไปหน้าฝนๆ 5 ตันตกค่ะฝนตกปั๊บ
เนี่ยตอนเช้าออกขาวออกเยอะเลย
วันที่เคยไปที่นี่ไหมคะเคยไปตอนครัวตี้ไป
ก็ฝนตกเหมือนกันฝนตกทั้งคืนฝนตกตอนกลาง
คืนแล้วตอนเช้าก็มีหมอกคือเป็นจังหวัด
เดียวเนาะที่ต้องเที่ยวตอนฝนตกปกตินะเรา
จะไม่เที่ยวกันหน้าฝนเค้าว่าอันตรายนะคะ
เพชรบูรณ์เป็นจังหวัดที่ต้องเที่ยวหน้าฝน
นะคะแล้วก็มีอีกหลายที่ที่น่าเที่ยวแล้ว
ก็อาหารอร่อยๆๆไม่ต้องอาหารเธอไป
เพชรบูรณ์ต้องไปกินอาหารค่ะอ่านอนอ่านอน
เต็นท์นอนเต็นท์นอนภูเขากินอาหาร
โอเคอ่าหมอมาที่จังหวัดเพชรบูรณ์เดี๋ยว
เราจะไปไหนไปที่ภาคอีสานบ้างครับที่ศาล
อุษาเราไปกันตั้งเยอะใจแต่ที่นี่เรายัง
ไม่เคยไปอ๋อเหรอใช่ครับเป็นเอ่อสถานที่
ธรรมชาติเหมือนกันที่น่าสนใจอีกที่หนึ่ง
นะครับก็มีชื่อเสียงนะที่นี่มีชื่อเสียง
ที่นี่ครับ
หาครูเห็นแบบนี้เกดคิดถึงอะไรครับพี่คิด
ถึงโฆษณาในทีวี
แล้วที่ทำให้อยากไปมาก
อยากไปยืนอยู่ตรงนี้เราก็ไปยืนอยู่ข้างบน
นี้อยากไปยืนแล้วก็ตะโกนดังๆอา
อาคิดถึงปลาวาฬ 5 มีคนยืนอยู่ข้างบนนี้
ครับตัวเล็กอยู่ตรงนี้หากูอะตี้จริงๆตัว
เองคิด 2 อย่างนะอ้าว x ตอนแรกที่กูเห็น
แบบนี้ตัวเองไม่คิดถึงปลาวาฬตัวเองคิดถึง
เรือดำน้ำออกๆๆกลัวนี่ก็คิดถึงก็เหมือน
เรือดำน้ำเหมือนกันเรยแล้วเรืออยู่ใต้น้ำ
อ่ะๆดำน้ำๆครับแล้วก็อีกอันนี้อยู่ที่ไหน
เพราะว่าเห็นเห็นรูปในเน็ตที่คนไปที่นี่
แล้วก็แบบโอ้ยอายยืนแล้วก็ต้องใหญ่มาก
ครับให้
คนต้นอ่าขอบคนไทยเรียกมันว่าหินสามวาฬอ่า
อ๋ออ่าเพราะว่ามันเหมือนดูแล้วเนี่ย
เหมือนกับปลาวาฬมันหลังของเราอะไรครับ
เหมือนหลังวานอยู่ในน้ำแล้วก็โผล่ขึ้นมา
จากน้ำนิดนึงเข็นตันหลักน่ะกูอะกูอะตี้
ปลาวาฬปลาวาฬหน้ากากเป็นยังไงอ่ะอ้าปลา
วาฬ
เป็นยังไงโอเคโอเค
ว่าในเป็นการ์ตูนนะคะแต่ว่าวาฬจริงๆก็
เป็นแบบนี้ล่ะค่ะตาลดำๆนะปลาวาฬก็จะมี
ลักษณะเป็นแบบนี้ใช่ไหมอ่ะ
คะอันนี้เมื่อกี้ส่วนเรื่องคนมันอยู่บน
ที่เราเห็นก็จะเป็นส่วนนี้ก็จะมีความจะ
พ่นน้ำขึ้นมันพ้นน้ำขึ้นมาอ่าชายก็จะอยู่
ในทะเล
เพราะว่าขวดอติวัฒน์เหมือนน่ะอ้ะเหมือนจะ
วัดกลมขึ้นมาฮ่าๆๆน่า xa เองก็เราสามารถ
ขึ้นไปเดินขึ้นไปเดินอยู่บนก้อนหินได้
ครับนี่ครับอันนี้อยู่ด้านล่างโหกินอยู่
แล้วแล้วเวลามองไปข้างๆนี่มันจะตื่นเต้น
แค่ไหนน่าตื่นเต้นเนี่ยเพราะข้างล่างก็จะ
เป็นหน้าผาลงไปเป็นป่าเป็นป่าเป็นหน้าผา
เราไว้ข้างล่างกันนี้แต่ไม่ลื่นตกใช่ไหม
คะเป็นไปไม่ลื่นครับเป็นพื้นที่จริงๆเป็น
พื้นที่กว้างครับกว้างกว้างของควรไม่ได้
เอียงแบบนี้ใช่ไหมค่ะไม่ไม่ไม่ได้เอียง
แบบแม่น้ำแหลมแบบนี้ที่อื่นไม่หลับเหมือน
ที่กลัวตีเคยไปเดินบนผู้เขาไม่ไม่ใช่เหรอ
แค่นั้นน่ากลัวกู Arty อันนี้ครูเอ๋น่ะก็
ตื่นเต้นเห็นแบบนี้นะคะตรงหน้าผากพี่ก็
เหมือนกันที่เค้ากระโดดงั้นกลัวว่าเขาจะ
ลื่นลงมาหรือเปล่าเอาแต่เป็นกว้างแบบนี้
บ้างครับว่างมากเนี่ยกว้างมาก้นเหลือต้น
เดียวนะครับกวางมากนี่อ่าเดินเล่นได้ไม่
อันตรายครับในอันตรายนะครับชิ้นสามวาฬยัง
ไม่เคยไปนะคะ 3 วันครับอยู่ที่อำเภอ
ภูสิงห์จังหวัดบึงกาฬชั้นนี้มีภูเขาพญา
นาคด้วยนะใช่ครับเพราะบึงกาฬเนี่ยก็ติด
กับแม่น้ำโขงค่ะติดกับแม่น้ำโขงคนไทยก็จะ
คิดถึงแม่น้ำโขงก็จะคิดพญานาคค่ะอ่าใส่
ครับชอบอันนี้นะคะอ่ะสวยใช่ไหมครับหวยถา
ไม้เขียวๆล้อมรอบก่อนหินอันนี้นะครับโอเค
อะไรนะ Unseen  In  Thailand ใช่มั้ยหน้า
ใจกับเป็นที่เที่ยวสถานที่ท่องเที่ยวที่
คนไม่ค่อยรู้จักชายก็เรียกว่าเป็นอันซีน
นะครับในประเทศไทยยังไม่เคยไปกูอันที่เคย
ไปหรือยังคะคะที่นี่ครัวที่เคยผ่านแต่ไม่
เคยแวะเข้าไปตอนนี้ควรตีไปที่จังหวัด
บึงกาฬตอนนั้นที่นี่ยังไม่เป็นที่รู้จัก
อ๋อยังไม่เปิดด้วยนะครับยังไม่เปิด
อนาคตต้องไปเนาะหน้าต้องไปอีกสักรอบหนึ่ง
ครับหน้ามีที่อื่นอีกไหมคะอ้าเดี๋ยวแวะไป
ที่นี่ครับจะไปที่อ่ะภาคตะวันออกบ้างพัก
ตอนออกเราไม่ค่อยได้ไปออใช่กูเองได้เป็น
คนภาคตะวันออกอ่าครับหน้าถ้างั้นเดี๋ยวพา
ไปนี่กับแสดงว่าที่นี่กูเอกก็ต้องรู้จัก
แน่ๆเลยชอบมากค่ะอ๋อที่ไหนครับเนี่ยอ้า
ที่จังหวัดชลบุรี
ไปพัทยา
อัตราบริเวณนั้นไม่เรียกว่าพัทยาเรียกว่า
นาเกลือนะคะน่าเกลียดจะอยู่ติดกับพัทยา
เหนือพัทยาก็มีพัทยาเหนือพัทยากลางพัทยา
ใต้จอมเทียน
ตรงเนี้ยบริเวณนี้เรียกวันนาเกลือก็อยู่
ติดกับทะเลใช่มั้ยทำนายเรือที่อยู่กับ
อะไรนะเอาวงเดือนอ๋ออ๋อมีเช่นเดียวเลยใช่
ไหมอ่ะต้องตรงนั้นน่ะเขาเรียกว่าอะไรนะ
บุญไหลออนซีอะไรสักอย่างเนาะอร่อยแล้วก็
มีชื่อมีชื่อเฉพาะด้วยอะแสดงว่าเป็นคน
เป็นคนภาคตะวันออกจริงๆเลยรู้ให้เขามีเขา
มีอะไรนะมีบังกะโลค่ะคุณเอกเคยไปอยู่ที่
นั่นไปไปไปเที่ยวที่นั่นนะคะก็เป็น b ชาย
หาดเป็นวงกลมแล้วก็ดูพระจันทร์สวยแล้ว
ซ้ายมือก็จะเป็น
ประสาทอันนี้อาชีวะประสาทสัจธรรมใช่ไหม
ครับใช้ค่ะประสาทสัจธรรมอะเพลงไม้ทั้ง
หลังเลยใช่มีความพิเศษกับประสาทอื่นก็คือ
ตรงที่สร้างดอกไม้ 5 สร้างมาจากไม้ทั้ง
หมดเลยว้าว
[เพลง]
นะไม้ไม้แกะสลักมหานักเรียนไม่มีแต่ปูเขา
ได้อะไรละน็อคดาวน์ใช่ไหมเออใช่ครับใช้
อ่าใช้ไม้มาทำสลัดในการประกอบขึ้นมาเป็น
ประสาทอันนี้ไม่ใช่กับกรวยใช้ไม้ทั้งหมด
เลยสวยมากนะคะโอเคแล้วก็เป็นประสาทไม้ที่
ใหญ่ที่สุดในโลกด้วยใช่ไหมครับชาย 5 ไม้
หมดทำมาจากไม้มาเลยเนี่ยแกะสลักเป็นรูป
สัตว์รูปอาบเทวดารูปเทพต่างๆหายหัวเลยนะ
เห็นตอนที่ยังทำไม่เสร็จอ่ะค่ะตอนที่
เสร็จแล้วนะเนี่ยไม่เคยเห็นอ๋ออ๋อใหญ่มาก
ครับใหญ่ห่างแล้วก็สวยมากด้วยวันที่เคยไป
ใช่ไหมคะคนที่เคยไปครับ
นะภาษาศาสตร์นักเรียนต้องไปดูนะคะใช่ค่ะ
ดอกไม้นะครับสำหรับคนที่ชอบ
เราบอกว่าศิลปะนี่ก็จะมีคนที่เรียนแกะจะ
ไม่ไม้ไงไม้มาเนี่ยอ้าได้งามๆแล้วก็แกะ
มายนะคะก็คนที่มีอาชีพแกะสลักไม้เขาก็จะ
มาแกะสลักไม้แล้วก็เอาไปทำเป็นธนาสารททำ
เป็นประสาทประดับเป็นเสาเป็นหนังสวยๆครับ
เป็นรูปเทวดารูปสัตว์ต่างๆเยอะแยะมากนะ
เนี่ยยากอยากว่า
ถ้าเข้าค่าเข้าเท่าไหร่คะตอนนี้ตอนนั้น
ค่าเข้าเท่าไหร่นะครับพี่กวาดติตอนนั้นไป
ไม่กี่บาทนะครับประมาณเหรอ 50  60 บาท
ประมาณนะคะได้ครับขนมตั้งแต่ 50  100 ตอน
นี้กี่ร้อยไม่ทราบขอ
แพงจิ้นแล้วใช่ไหมขนแกะสลักต้องกินข้าวนะ
คะนักเรียนเยอะอย่าไปบอกว่าเฮ้ยทำไมแพง
จังแต่คนแกะสลักเขากำลังกินข้าวอ่าไปจะ
ได้จะได้มีประสาทสวยๆให้เราดูนานๆมายครับ
เพราะว่าเป็นไม้งับเป็นไม้ก็จะอยู่ได้ไม่
นานก็ต้องดูแลรักษาอ่าบ่อยๆนะครับ
อ้า
อันนี้กูกลับมีอีกที่อยู่ที่น่าสนใจที่
ไหนคะแหล่งท่องเที่ยวของอ่ะเป็นธรรมชาติ
อีกเหมือนกันครับเดี๋ยวลงไปทางป้ายครับ
ที่นี่ไม่ได้ชลบุรีจากชลบุรีภาคตะวันออก
แล้วจะไปทางภาคใต้แล้วครับนี่ครับพี่
เมื่อกี้กวนตีสถานีแล้วรู้ไหมไม่รู้
สิบๆไอ้ไปเกาะหลายๆกรอบนะคะแต่ที่เนี่ย
ไม่เคยไปฮ่าๆๆที่นี่เขามีชื่ออีกชื่อ
หนึ่งเป็นชื่อเล่นนะครับชื่อเล่นว่าเป็น
กุ้ยหลินเมืองไทย
วิลเลจประเทศจีนไม่ใช่ที่เพจนี้เลยหรอไม่
ติดเพื่อนไทย
เล่นขายกันจะเป็นเกาะที่เล็กไม่เดินไม่
ได้หรอได้อับเดินไม่ได้ครับหน้านักเรียน
เห็นรูปนี้ล่ะจะคิดโอ้โหที่นี่ที่เอ่อ
ในอะไรนะที่เอาไว้ปลาครับที่ไหนนะแผ่นโด
ล่าครับเป็นเกาะแพนโดร่าในเรื่องอวตารจำ
ได้ไหมเอาอ่ะตา
on  OK ให้ขายกันครับไฟๆกัน
แล้วก็เข้าบัญชีก็ดูหนังหนังต่างประเทศ
อ่ะเป็น
ถ่ายทำเรื่องอีกประเทศหนึ่งแล้วก็ถ่ายที่
นี่เหมือนกันอ๋ออ่าใช่ครับแต่ที่นี่เนี่ย
เป็นเขื่อนนะครับเพราะว่าหาอ่าน้ำที่เป็น
น้ำจืดนะครับเป็นจุดนำเขตทะเลอาเกาะอยู่
ในน้ำจืดใช่ครับเป็นเขื่อน
สร้างเขื่อนที่ใช้ผลิตกระแสไฟฟ้าแล้วนี้
ก็เป็นน้ำที่อยู่ในเขื่อนค่ะอ่าที่นี่
อยู่ที่จังหวัดสุราษฎร์ธานีครับค่ะเรียก
ว่าอะไรครับผมที่นี่เลยนะเป็นอุทยานแห่ง
ชาติกับอุทยานแห่งชาติเขาศพงูอุทยานแห่ง
ชาติเขาส่งชาติเขาสุกเค้าก็จะมีส่วนที่
เป็นป่าที่ไทยเยอะด้วยอ้ามีป่ามีภูเขามี
ต้นไม้เยอะๆด้วยแล้วก็มีส่วนที่เป็น
เขื่อนค่ะก็จะคือที่นี่ที่คณะเรืองนั่ง
เรือได้ใช่ไหมคะถ้ามีเรือบริการให้นัก
ท่องเที่ยวเนี่ยไปนั่งไปชมภูเขาต่างๆรอบๆ
บริเวณในเขื่อนนะครับหน้านอกจากมีเรือ
แล้วเนี่ยยังมีมีที่พักอยู่ที่นั่นด้วยมี
รีสอร์ทมีกิจกรรมทางน้ำสามารถไปพายเรือ
คายัคให้เรือแคนูเล่นดาอาไปเล่นน้ำที่นี่
ได้ด้วยมีรีสอร์ทติดกับเขื่อนเลยนะคะๆ
รีสอร์ทก็อยู่ในดูกันเลยค่ะอาหารเคยไปไหม
คะที่น่ากลัวติ๊กไม่เคยไปนอนที่นี่ครับ
เคยนะครับรถผ่านไป R แต่คิดว่าคิดว่าถ้า
มีโอกาสจะไปนอนจะไปนอนที่นี่สักฤดูไหนดี
คะอ้าฤดูที่แนะนำก็
ร้อนกับหนาวร้อนเพราะว่าเล่นน้ำได้ค่ะอาจ
จะได้เป็นเล่นน้ำได้ถ้าเกิดอยู่ไปเที่ยว
เขื่อนแบบนี้ไม่แนะนำฤดูฝนเนาะตายครับดู
ฝนมีอยู่ที่เดียวเลยเพชรบูรณ์นะคะฮ่าๆฮ่า
ไปเขื่อนแบบนี้แนะนำฤดูร้อนฤดูหนังอยู่
หนาวใช่ค่ะแต่ว่าภาคใต้ก็ไม่มีถ้าจะไม่
หนาวอย่าหาทรายครับจะมีฝนกับร้อนหน้าฝนจะ
ตกอย่ามากกว่ามากกว่าภาคอื่นๆของประเทศ
ไทยน่า
น่าไปน่าไปครับมีอีกไหมอ่ะนะครับเรายังมี
เวลาเหลืออีกนิดหน่อยครับมีที่ท่องเที่ยว
ที่น่าสนใจในประเทศไทยอีกเดี๋ยวครัวตี้พา
ไปที่นี่ครับถ้าไปไหนคะให้พาไปแล้วครั้ง
หนึ่งที่กาญจนบุรีแต่เราไม่ได้แวะที่นี่
วันนี้เราจะไปแวะที่นี่แหละ
หาที่นี่มะไปไปกาญจนบุรีไม่ไปที่นี่ไม่
ได้
จอดทีที่ไหนครับนี่สะพานค่ะอ้าสะพานสะพาน
ข้ามน้ำแม่น้ำอะไรไหมหาแม่น้ำแควน้อยหา
แม่น้ำชื่อแขวนนะคะนักเรียนอะไรครับไม่
ว่านักเรียนบางคนจะออกเสียงตัวนี้ไม่ได้
นะคะฮ่าๆๆตอบเสียงเป็นอะไรครับเอาถึงไม่
เป็นไรอ่ะแอลเหรอ
นักเรียนออกเสียงนะคะแต่เราใหญ่
Kwai นะคะหน้าแม่หนึ่งแปล
สะพานนี้ที่สะพานสะพานที่ให้รถไฟวิ่งข้าม
นะครับใช่ทนายแต่ว่ารถเขาจะมีทัวร์รถไฟ
ใช่ตอนนี้ยังมีหรือเปล่ากูเองในนะใจแต่
เมื่อก่อนจะมีตอนที่ยังมีอยู่ครับนี้นะคะ
จากกรุงเทพฯแล้วก็ไปกาญจนบุรีแล้วก็กลับ
แล้วเขาก็จุดที่เขาจะจอดก็คือที่นี่
หนึ่งจุดที่เขาจะจอดแล้วก็ให้เราเนี่ยลง
ไปเราก็ขายรูปกับสะพานขับแปลกนะถ่ายรูป
ออกมาแล้วนะเราจะดูสวยขึ้น
ครู a นะรู้สึกว่ากูเอกเคยไปครั้งสอง
ครั้ง
ครั้งแรกเนี่ยตอนอายุ 18
คือเรียนจะจบแล้วก็ก็เพื่อนๆน่ะก็เลยยก
ขบวนไปกันประมาณ 40 คนได้บ้างครับถ้าว้าว
ไปกันเยอะเลยน่ารักก็ถ่ายรูปคะแล้วก็อีก
ครั้งหนึ่งก็คือพานักเรียนไปเที่ยวครูละ
ไปเที่ยวก็ไม่ถ่ายรูปเหมือนกันแล้วเอ๊ย
ทำไมสะพานนี้ถ่ายมาแล้วเนี่ยเราดูสวยขึ้น
แสงด้วยคะกาญจนบุรีนี่ร้อนมากใช่ครับแสง
แล้วก็สะพานสีดำก็จะทำให้หน้าเราเนี่ย
อ้วนดูสว่างว่าใส่ไงเพราะเราก็จะมีสีตัด
กับสีสะพานใช่มั้ยก็มีแสงสว่างแสงเยอะเรา
ก็ถ่ายรูปได้ดีๆควรจะใส่เสื้อสีขาวสีแดง
สีฟ้าสีส้มนะคะอาจจะได้สว่างสว่างใช่ไหม
ไอ้ห่า
กากจะมีรถไฟแบบนี้ๆใช่ครับมีสำหรับคนที่
ไม่ได้นั่งขับรถไปนะครับแต่ไม่อยากนั่งรถ
ไปเนี่ยก็มีรถไฟบริการ
หารถไฟบริการใช่เราวิ่งสั้นๆวิ่งอยู่บน
สะพานเนี่ยครับกับนิดหน่อยก็ขอ 20 บาทอ๋อ
อ้านั่งเล็กนั่งเล่นสนุกๆก็ได้บรรยากาศ
วันนั่งรถไปข้ามสะพานฮ่าๆๆแล้วก็ทุกปีจะ
มีแสงสีเสียงที่นี่ 5 มีงานมีงาน
มีงานมีแสงมีมี
อะไรเยอะแยะที่หนึ่งในครับเป็นงานเหรอ
เทศกาลประจำประจำปีทุกๆปีอะไรครับถึง
กาญจนบุรีคิดถึงไอ้ๆกับสะพานข้ามแม่น้ำ
แควก็จะมีที่พักด้วยนะเราสามารถไปนอนริม
แม่น้ำแควน้อยเนี่ยเป็นแพไหมคะอ้าอันนี้
เป็นเป็นที่พักอยู่บนแพมันแพ้เนาะงานแต่
ก็จะมีที่พักอีกประเภทหนึ่งที่เป็นแพ้
แล้วก็เราสามารถลอยไปตามแม่น้ำได้อ๋อกด
หาถ้าแบบนี้ก็สะดวกดีครับเราสมมติเราไปมี
คนค่ะไปกับครอบครัว 4-5 คนแล้วก็พักที่
พักแบบนี้ได้ค่ะอะไรวะหลายๆคน
หลายๆคนใช่มันก็ไปกันหลายๆคนเราก็เช่าแผล
เป็นหลังหลังใหญ่ๆแล้วก็ลอยไปตามแม่น้ำ
โอ้ยพี่กูเองถามผู้ Arty ว่าชอบแบบไหน
เนี่ย
ผิดลอยไปนะไปไหน
เขาจะมีเรือเค้าจะมีเรือลากไปด้วยอ่านอน
ไปก็ตื่นเช้าขึ้นมาที่ไหนนะถ้าอยู่คนละ
ที่กับไม่ได้อยู่ที่เดิมนะ OK ขอนอนอยู่
กับพี่นะคะฮ่าๆๆถ้าขับรถไปนอนอยู่กับพี่
ก็ดีครับตื่นมาจะได้ออกเดินกลับไปที่รถ
ได้ถ้า
เปิดแพนอ่ะนอนแผลที่เขารักไปอ่ะค่ะอับ
ตื่นมาอีกทีหนึ่งแล้วเขาลากกลับที่เดิม
ไหมคะอะไรกับเขาจะลากกลับมาที่เดิมโอเค
ค่ะนึกว่านึกว่าไปแล้วก็ต้องขึ้นรถที่
นู่นแล้วก็กลับมาคุณหมอที่พักน่านั่งนะ
นอนนะที่พักบรรยากาศดีครับอากาศดีดีนะ
ครับแล้วก็เขามีกิจกรรมให้ด้วยนะครับ
สำหรับนักท่องเที่ยวที่ไปหาก็จะมีกิจกรรม
ไปว่ายน้ำบางทีเขาก็จะให้นั่งเรือไปแล้ว
เขาจะปล่อยเราลงในแม่น้ำและก็ลอยมาตามน้ำ
อะแล้วก็จะมีเรือไปรับอยู่อีกอีกสัตว์
ต้องใส่เสื้อชูชีพเสื้อชูชีพด้วยครับถ้า
ไปกับจะเป็นแม่น้ำที่กว้างลงไปนี่น้ำเย็น
มากเงียบเลยอ่ะเออตอนก่อนลงไปโอ๋โอ้ยน้ำ
เย็นคือกูเอกเคยไปแต่ไม่เคยลงน้ำก็ไม่เคย
นอนแพที่นี่แต่ไปนอนอีกที่หนึ่งที่อะไรนะ
สังขละสังฆะบุรีใช่ไหมครับจะเป็นอีกที่
หนึ่งของกาญจนบุรีค่ะนักเรียนที่ไปใกล้
ใกล้ที่จะปิดไปเมียนมาร์แล้วอ่ะติดกับ
ประเทศพม่าใช่ไหมครับที่นั่นก็จะมีหมู่
บ้านดูบอลใช่ไหมให้ไม่มีโทรศัพท์ใช้ไม่
ได้อ่ะคอมพิวเตอร์ใช้ไม่ได้ไม่มีไม่มีไฟ
ไม่มี WiFi ครับไม่มีอะไรคือไปที่นั่นคือ
ไม่มีสัญญาณเป็นพิภักดิ์ผ่อนจริงๆอ่าน
หนังสือนอนฟังเสียงน้ำว่ายน้ำได้นะคะเดิน
เล่นนะโอเคอ่ะ
โอเคก็ก็วันนี้เราก็เก็บตกที่เที่ยว
ที่น่าสนใจอีกหลายๆที่นะครับที่เบอร์รี่
คลิปนักเรียนหน้าชอบนะครับนะครับหน้าก็
ปิดท้ายอ่าอ่าเรียกว่าอะไรนี้รี่นี้เลย
เอาไปเที่ยวนะคะเท่าไหร่นะครับถ้ามีที่
ไหนที่นักเรียนเคยไปแล้วควรที่กับครูเอ๋
ยังไม่ได้พูดถึงก็แนะนำกันมาได้ครับเผื่อ
ได้ห่ามันดูคลิปนี้แล้วจะได้ไปบ้างนะแต่
ถ้าได้ค่ะเราก็ไม่บอกเอ๊ยน่าจะไปเราก็อาจ
จะไปเที่ยวกันเองอ่าโอเคครับผม
จบแล้วสิรินนี้แล้วนะครับเดี๋ยวเขาน่า
คูเอกกลัวที่จะมีเรื่องอะไรมาเล่าหรือว่า
ยังไม่รู้คอยติดตามกันทุกหน้าแล้ววันนี้
กูเอกก็ลาไปก่อนแล้วครับ / สวัสดีค่ะ
บ๊ายบาย